- All right, y'all.
I always like to close out the show
with something cool that will hopefully
leave all of us feeling happy.
This is What I'm Liking.
(audience clapping)
There are so many mysteries in
this ever expanding universe.
Like, have you ever thought about
what's going on miles
below the ocean surface?
The bizarre creatures, plant
life that actually survives.
I watch these shows all the time.
I'm obsessed.
One of my favorite aquariums,
the Monterey aquarium here in
California has a new exhibit,
that's giving people an up close
and personal glimpse of what
happens deep down in the sea.
It's super cool.
And I wanted them to tell us all about it.
So we have the director of
interpretive programs, Natalia
on the line right now.
She watches on KSBW eight.
What's up.
- Hi, Kelly.
How are you?
- Hello.
Oh, I've actually been
where you're kinda standing.
I love that.
So it's great to meet you.
I'm totally geeking
out about this exhibit.
I cannot wait to come back.
So putting this exhibition on,
this has been kind of crazy, right?
It's been quite the feat, right?
- Yes. I mean that doesn't even cover it.
We have had R and D years in the making
to open up into the deep
our undiscovered oceans.
Guests that come get to go
as if they're diving down themselves.
They start here in front of the open sea
and then they take a deep dive,
where they could see over
50 different species.
We have our bloody belly comb jelly,
say that five times fast.
But the coolest thing is that
some of these animals
have never been exhibited,
and this exhibit will
have quite a long run.
So you might come back
in a couple of years
and see totally different animals.
It's really, really exciting.
- That's so cool.
And it looks like they
just, it looks futuristic.
It's all like (Kelly beeps).
All the color, it's so cool.
Was, I'm like a child.
I'm like 40 years old
and I'm a child still.
Was it tough to put the exhibit together?
'Cause you're trying to like,
remake what's happening
miles down the ocean, so.
- Yeah. And you know, one
of the original visions
of one of our founders, David
Packard, was what would happen
if you put engineers
and scientists together?
You get into the deep,
you get this exhibit
because the engineers
use their engineering
to put together things like
remotely operated vehicles,
where we could actually travel down deep
where humans can't go.
And collect these animals in
the way that doesn't harm them.
And then our scientists come in,
and they figure out exactly
just the right pH of the water,
how cold it needs to be,
and all of the animal care side
to actually exhibit these animals,
so you and I could see them.
- It is so cool.
Thank you so much, Natalia.
I cannot wait to come back and see y'all.
I'm so stoked about it.
I'm liking your post right now, okay?
(audience clapping)
- Yay. Thank you.
Please. Come back.
- All right, well that's not all.
Our season long partner
Pilot Pen makers of G2,
the go-to pen of the Kelly Clarkson show
want to honor ultimate over achievers.
I would definitely say
that's your entire team
at the Monterey aquarium.
So they're gonna be writing
the aquarium a check
for a thousand dollars.
(audience cheering)
- Thank you, Kelly.
Thank you so so much.
- [Kelly] Thank you so much, Natalia.